you would not be able to walk we're
watching the daredevil water this seems
great because thank you to today's
sponsor expressvpn for bringing you this
episode to stay tuned at the end to
learn how to get three months free
what's up guys hey welcome back to
another episode of stuntman react we are
joined by Eric Linden master stunt
coordinator stunt extraordinaire
he's got the flips he's got the kicks
welcome Eric's gonna give us a bunch of
great insight some really cool scenes
from movies some things you may not have
known we're gonna be educated today all
right let's get to it
oh yeah beep oh man
by the way when the buildings explode
there's literally dummies on stands in
front and you can see them very clearly
you can see the stand on the back of the
guy I miss old school pyrotechnics like
this I want to be a pyrotechnic actually
is my first thing when I came to movies
oh really yeah bigger power technician
was like my main drive I got close
enough I definitely watched this like on
VHS back when I was younger watching it
now like they actually doing like some
really good stunt work those dudes
diving out of that car like literally
there's they're like okay so you're
gonna ride in this car we're gonna do a
small pipe ramp and just bail when you
get when you feel ready to do it's right
yeah try out to die
there's another trend that like luckily
is like just gone away is people just
kind of like doing the like they get hit
like yeah how dedicated is your
paramilitary force to still fight back
against what manganese murdered half
your school oh yeah each one of them's
like I'm the guy this guy does the most
graceful twist they're like we need a
gymnast to take a grenade hit that
there's an area oh wow there's blatantly
in the frame what's an errand hey air
Rams like almost like a reverse bear
trap where this this thing is is it's
closed like this and when the guy steps
on it it hits a switch and a pneumatic
opens like that he gets catapulted
through the air and you've done air and
hits before right oh yeah do you ever
worry about like your legs buckling out
from under you a hundred percent if you
hit it and you're kind of not like
locked out like not with your knee
locked out but your quad completely
flexed it will just buckle your leg and
I I mean there's been cases where people
have their legs have buckled right and
they've gone up in the air so then they
would land back on it and fire off it's
almost like a dinosaur thing that they
don't really do anymore because they
weren't really wiping wires in this now
when we would you know a guy goes flying
down the hill or Batman throws him
across thing you're you're gonna use
wire work to get them there and you can
wipe the wire so easily now it's almost
not worth it you're gonna end up erasing
the air ram later anyway yeah now air
Rams might be dinosaur technology but I
love me some dinosaurs special effects
so you guys may have seen me get little
on fire by Erik Lyndon you guys want to
see me launch off of an air ram through
the air maybe off of a cliff please
leave a comment down in the comments
let's get back to the video I really
love that type of like like the squibs
and stuff like that that's just like the
filmmaking that that was the way they
always used to do it like I I'm not like
a big fan of like CG unless it's used
very subtly I mean I think when it comes
to like showcasing danger and like human
talent when you get computers involved
in that we were trying to actually show
the feat of grace or strength or Avery
adding CG to that takes away from that
aspect of it because there's still a bit
of reality in films you know when
somebody's going to do a crazy
motorcycle jump or a triple flip crash
into like a wall you still I think it's
important to like recognize the reality
of having a human really go out there
and put themselves on the line to do
that shot and CG can really take away
from that this scene is great this is
really what these people kind of went
through you would have a duel you know
you kind of seem like there's some you
know
click-clack and somebody gets stabbed
and they die however often times you
wouldn't die you would just kind of get
picked apart and start to bleed to death
which makes your energy wear down you're
dealing with pain and if you get hit in
the wrong spot like you may not be able
to use your arm or use it properly you
know he's been struck and his sword arm
so he uses his other arm to like hold up
that arm it's just like a small detail
that that they did a really great job
with when you like look at something
like the Phantom Menace you know you can
pick apart parts where they're just
completely not aiming at each other's
vital parts they're not aiming for their
head and they're kind of making blocks
out in the middle of nowhere right I'm a
thrust way over here off to the side
because I want your sword to come to
block it so that I can then turn come
around and cut at your throat
see how Liam hits the sword yeah because
you can hit the flat part of it without
cutting your hand it's real quick but
that's kind of some of this stuff like
as a fight coordinator when you can find
those little things
it's just isn't what everybody else is
gonna do yeah it's not the most flashy
thing in the world but as far as like
really feeling and those beats in
between they kind of like build the
tension and the hero you've been
watching the whole time is like clearly
losing and ultimately I mean he loses
but that arrogance got the better of
[Music]
Oh how'd you get for being pompous so
think this does a great job is just
showing a real sword fight like just how
brutal it truly was so we actually look
at the stats for these videos in like
sixty percent of the viewers who watch
these videos aren't subscribed to the
channel they're not subscribed yeah
there's like 60% of the people that
watch aren't subscribe why did you and
subscribe you myself I will find you and
I will subscribe you we're watching the
daredevil one er this scene in
particular I think it's like perfect and
also my good buddies are the ones that
did it so like it's fantastic
he goes into the door that's Charlie the
actor door closes stunt double comes out
stunt double is Chris Brewster it's a
fantastic way of using with Texas which
actor goes behind a barrel out of door
without cutting the stunt double comes
out stunt double then does whatever it
is that he needs to do goes behind a
pole or some sort of obstacle and the
actor has now moved into the correct
position he gets up continues on
another thing I think they did really
good job of and daredevil as a whole is
he'll do spinny flippy type of things
but that's inherently the character of
daredevil that was portrayed in the
comics and everything and the stunt
coordinator did an amazing job doing
these flips in like a manner that made
sense
it wasn't like gratuitous it seemed to
work within the flow of the choreography
hello belly comes off the wall there
yeah he's exhausted yeah I think they do
a great job of kind of like some of the
stuff that they did in Rob Roy the hero
is getting tired you know he's not
superhuman per se although he is like a
highly trained guy you know he's taken
some hits you can see that he's not
always making the perfect move and
sometimes he pays for it now I love it
when you see a little bit of
vulnerability from the hero's stunt
double goes back into the door and and
then of course the actor comes back out
and finishes the scene people always
wonder if that hallway scene that we
just saw is a true one ER and the answer
is yes I think they did it 12 times and
they ended up using I think that tenth
or eleventh one
so this one is another famous daredevil
Warner they use camera wipes to create
this water so it is not a true Warner
but they were able to kind of up the
ante there real slick cuz they were
doing wipes on where you could barely
even tell CG chain yeah little wire work
there yeah the stairs are all padded
they put into light on every single
staircase Charlie who plays daredevil is
a fantastic fighter he did a ton of his
own fighting he's amazing I fought him
on the rooftop you know he kind of like
gives me a push kick and I'm like dude
just give it to me this dude hits so
hard the next day I woke up and
literally had a footprint bruised on my
chest he's a great actor and a
phenomenal fighter so this is one of our
most commented on movies to talk about
please leave a comment below if there's
something you would love to see us react
to to talk about we love reading them
it's a great inspiration so please do
not hold back all right
I'm a big fan of like the the little
pauses where they're letting tension
build they're sizing each other up or
stuff like when qui gonn sits and
meditates while Maul wants to just tear
him apart looks like good pacing good
contrast you know yeah it's great I'm
just waiting for somebody to grab like a
hot pan and like throat uh dude dude you
would not be able to walk does it make
you wonder what I didn't didn't do that
to begin yeah did he feel like he was
losing and he decided to pull that out
though Thanks
or was he just sick of it I've gotten
through two windows and a couple wine
bottles yeah yeah
so in the part where he traps his leg I
noticed they're using the dropped frame
technique which is a great way to add
some punch to your shots when you're
doing action movies you watch the
movement of his feet here every frame
things kind of move the same distance
like it spoke moves from here to here
then here to here then here to here it's
an equal movement boom you'll notice
that his foot jumps twice the distance
that's been moving every other frame you
can just cut out that one frame of
acceleration and it just makes an impact
sale so much harder and I mean I think
that's eco just just literally I think
you they just Pat up a little bit and
they go for it I think these guys are
clearly like true savages how long do
you think it took you for them to film
that probably a week no week at least
I'd be really fast I feel like four if
you're only doing the fighting and
you've already previz everything because
I believe that that director does
something very specific where he shoots
for the Edit like he kind of knows like
I need this much for this shot and I
think it's because they they previz it a
lot so that then they shoot just what
they need you know just like that bottle
thing where you goes boom and blocks the
bottle if you already know where you're
going and you know if that works you
know you you're just using that one bead
of it so they could have very well shot
that once and been done another thing
that stands out to me about this action
scene that really says how well-designed
it is is that they are against a bright
white background and there's still a
whets are easy to read now there's a
trend in Hollywood movies to have guys
in black fighting guys in black against
dark black backgrounds and you can't
really follow the action whereas in this
scene it's way more easy to follow
hey guys welcome back to brand guy
reacts too bad and great brands I've got
Nico here with me I've got Clint guys
thanks for being here today let's just
jump into it see we got today expressvpn
is a premium Virtual Private Network
service
oh man expressvpn do I love these guys
not only have they been a huge sponsor
of the show for a really long time but
they're also sponsored today's episode I
mean oh stop right there yeah as you
know they have like first-class internet
privacy protection yeah oh yeah I
definitely recognize that yeah
now guys as you know without a VPN all
of your internet browsing data can be
tracked by ISPs cell phone providers
companies and guess what hackers so huge
props to expressvpn for protecting
people out there was that as they do
their daily searches did you did you
have anything you wanted to say about
this Nico the IP address you use is one
of thousands yeah can you go frame by
frame this is one of my favorite parts
so you see what they did is is they made
expressvpn available in over 94
countries which means no matter where
you are in the world you basically get
the fastest speeds out of any VPN
service provider and they also gave you
24/7 customer service you can get help
whenever you need it oh and they made
browser extensions available for things
like Chrome and Safari so it's super
easy to use when you're just browsing
around them on the net you can get a
subscription for less than seven bucks
months with a 30-day money-back
guarantee all you have to do is go to
expressvpn comm slash corridor crew niko
come on man you know how to spell it
it's right there on the monitor you just
go to exp re SS VPN comm slash corridor
crew and you can get three months free
when you sign up for a year but anyway
that's that's about the end of the
episode so if you guys want to see us
react to any other brands just let us
know in the comments below we'll be
going through
everyone thank you for watching you
happen to be active on reddit we
actually have a corridor subreddit our
South Corridor it'll be a link down in
the description it's a great way to get
in touch with us leave your quests of
course can leave a comment in this video
but it's just another avenue to
communicate with us also if you're
interested in getting into Stan's Eric
actually has like a frequently asked
questions thing that he's put together
that answers a lot of those questions
it's a really good info but otherwise
you just have really cool scenes you
want to talk about or just want to tell
him good job he's a badass you can go
and follow him at Eric Linden awesome
thanks a lot for having me guys love
doing these appreciate it